i'll tell you what i think one of the
problems is a lot of conservatives
seem to think that donald trump needed
to do all the work for him and not
not just conservatives conservatives had
been the one paying attention to this
more than than liberals were like you
know in the story you told you were kind
of unaware of what's going on i told a
similar story in 2014
conservatives have seen this and have
been railing on it for some time
then moderates got roped in and now many
liberals people like barry weiss for
instance are complaining about what
happened at the new york times
and you have anti-woke leftists even now
criticizing the establishment and what
they call neoliberalism
the problem is a lot of conservatives
thought donald trump was the answer
i'm not saying every single one or at
least they thought trump would be
some kind of assistance and they're not
entirely wrong
trump did come in and he did eventually
sign you know uh enact this executive
order but it took what james lindsay and
christopher ruffo
going on you know shows chris of rufo
going on tucker carlson
and saying this is a problem for trump
to enact this what in the last several
months of office
the issue is these government agencies
had been doing
absolutely racist practices in one
instance there was like i think it was
there was a certain laboratory sent all
the white people on a retreat to like
talk about
whiteness and white privilege and why
it's you know bad and things like that
we've seen many stories like that
christopher ruffo documents all of these
you know there's a bunch of examples
every single one of those people needed
to file a lawsuit they needed to do what
you are doing right now
so what ends up happening is we have
years of this
and we have many people complaining
about it but where are the people
actually
filing the suits challenging these these
institutions
on was it title seven of the 1964 civil
rights act you cannot discriminate on
the basis of race
and and gender and national origin and
things like that
when i saw donald trump was enacting
this executive order i thought to myself
he shouldn't have to do this it's
already illegal
it's interesting we had a leftist on
this show
who argued that trump was banning you
know free speech and that it was wrong
to do this and i'm like
it's already illegal to do these
programs you cannot take a bunch of
white people off to a retreat and tell
them white people are bad
that violates the law the law says race
the law doesn't say marginalized groups
you can argue the spirit or the intent
but it doesn't matter
we have these laws for a reason joe
biden has come in
rescinded the executive order and it
doesn't change the fact it's still
illegal
that means every single person who works
in the government works in these
universities or is affected by the
wokeness
needs to be filing a lawsuit today
against these institutions for what
they're doing
why aren't they doing it well
we talked about money that's right
that's a huge thing i mean
really it's even before that the
question is why
i mean i i feel like more people are
speaking out but i mean
people don't even talk about it
let alone file lawsuit i mean that's
like a big that's a big step that's a
commitment
and litigation is difficult
um we do have some other lawsuits going
on in this country though
we have a uh clark versus clark v
democracy prep in nevada which is a
school case
uh it's a k-12 charter school
the gabrielle's son is a senior
and he was uh forced i mean
they said they would give him a d-minus
if he didn't profess his
is this the biracial yes so we actually
have looks white he's like you
well that's that's that's a really
there's a really funny thing about that
uh
whether i'm white appearing or not
depends on the the race of the
individual
no joke so in my experience i've
i've i've been called hispanic more than
anything else latino
i had a guy occupy wall street refer to
me as his puerto rican brother and i'm
like bro i'm not hispanic i mean i know
like the tiny bit of spanish because i
grew up in chicago
but i was in uh anaheim and i had the
guys from telemundo walk up to me
speaking spanish
just assuming i was you know latino to a
certain extent
and so it really is in the eye of the
beholder the funny thing is
if i agree with the woke all of a sudden
they can see that i'm not white
and they sent this they say see it's
because you understand if i disagree
with them they say you're white
that's that's that's the name of the
game yeah because it's it's not really
about
skin colors it's about politics yeah
it's about whether you you are in the
cult or not so
let me jump to the story we have this
from the atlanta black star
they say black mom sues school after she
says biracial son received
failing grade in sociology class for
refusing to confess
his white dominance a black mom is suing
her biracial son's nevada charter school
after she claims he received a failing
grade for refusing to link aspects of
his identity to oppression and dominance
in a sociology class
gabrielle clark and her son william
clark filed a suit in u.s district court
of nevada
against public charter school democracy
prep agassi campus in vegas on december
22
alleging a violation of constitutional
free speech and due process rights
william clark claims that in that class
sociology of change taught by catherine
bass
who was named as a defendant in the suit
he was harassed
and punished for refusing to attach
derogatory labels
to aspects of his identity clark whose
deceased father was white
is generally regarded as white by his
peers according to the complaint
and has green eyes and blondish hair the
far right advocacy group
international organization for the
family which has been tracking the case
closely reports
that a us district court judge said at a
february 22nd
temporary restraining order hearing i
think william is likely to succeed
on the merits of his compelled speech
claims saying that the defendants will
have to find a way to justify the
critical race theory curriculum
under a strict scrutiny test adding
that's a very high bar to me
in the class taught by bass a
self-described white irish-american
citizen clark was allegedly forced to
reveal his race
gender sexual and religious identities
and attach labels to the identities
which the lawsuit claims violated his
right to privacy
an instructional slide included in court
documents displays dominant groups in
american culture as white
male middle upper class heterosexual and
protestant christian
while everyone else is categorized as
submissive
labels like white are associated with
bass are associated by bass with
privilege while words like female and
working class
are associated with oppressive it's
really
twisted this kind of stuff yeah
yeah that's that's a particularly
egregious but this is happening
all over the place you know um and
gabrielle clark stood up and said no no
thanks i'm not i'm not going to do this
i was given a similar one of my
colleagues was like
offered to help uh educate me and i took
her up on it i was like okay
um i'm gonna i'm gonna have an open mind
and she handed me a worksheet and it did
have that
the oppressed it was two columns
oppressed
and um it was dominant group and
subordinated group and the dominant
group only had like one thing like
race was white gender male religion
christian you know and and then over
here you had all like everybody else in
the entire world and i was like wow
that was a very reductionist view of the
world but that sounds it's very similar
to what
uh william experienced and i believe i
think he was the only white presenting
person in his class
too which made it especially
have you taken have you taken the
privilege test where it's like a slider
bar and it's like how white are you how
christian are you how old are you oh the
intersectionality score
yeah something like that then it's like
you are 74 points privileged out of 100
you are very privileged or whatever
yeah that's basically what they're doing
uh have you ever seen that that
image of the three people staying at the
fence for the
equality equity of course the amazing
thing about that is is its manipulation
it's the
the insidiousness of it where they show
that to children
and they explain very simply hey we can
give
you know one of the one of the boxes
from the tall guy to the short guy so
they can all see right
well that's simple it makes sense but
what happens when you're dealing with
race
and orientation and national origin and
religion it's impossible to quantify
how standing on top of religion allows
you to see a baseball game
so these are the kinds of manipulative
tactics they use where you kind of
understand it but here's here's what i
truly despise about this
that equality versus equity argument is
about wealth
not race the person who everyone who
gets access to
a a a box to stand on
is their access to resources giving the
shorter person two boxes
is giving them access to resources to
help them
the argument that we actually need to be
having is about class issues
well they do mention working class and
middle upper class as part of the
oppression scale
but when they when they make everything
about your race
that that in my opinion is meant to
disrupt
actual what's what's the right word for
it i guess
social justice real social justice oprah
all of a sudden becomes oppressed
and she's a billionaire and then a white
homeless veteran
is now an oppressor because he's white
yeah it's like saying oprah winfrey has
more in common with
um somebody living in is it east
like the marcy projects in new york yeah
than than a wealthy white person
right clearly that's a false but that's
that's that's the kind of narrative they
use like they they used it with serena
williams
when she had uh so she's the famous
tennis player
when she had a bout of rage you know
with all due respect
she got angry and she like bounced her
tennis racket or something like that
they they they penalized her for it and
then there was this big narrative that
the only reason they did it was because
she was
a black woman and that they were
basically attacking her as the trope of
the angry black woman
as opposed to the fact that she just
acted out in violation of the rules
and to act like one of the most famous
celebrated and wealthy athletes in the
world is in any way oppressed
is just shockingly i don't know
ignorant in my opinion but i i think
it's part of the weaponization that we
see from a lot of people i mean
heaven forbid there's a large push
towards
you know stripping away the resources of
corrupt politicians who somehow make
millions of dollars off of their office
when they're getting a salary for 174
000 a year and then also become worth 50
million dollars or 5 million
or whatever they don't want you to come
after him so they'll say hey don't look
at me
it's the uh uh it's the white guy go
yell at that guy in the gutter who's you
know
shoveling garbage for a living he's the
real oppressor
they teach it yeah it's just like uh
jackie blair is the
the dining person who was falsely
accused is the
the real oppressor yeah the janitor
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you